hey guys what's up you guys request a
new game of thrones so we got some new
backstory on the original fate of
Stannis the George R Martin intended
that completely changes his character
from what we saw in the TV show careful
for spoilers for everything that's
happened on the show so far and if
you're new to the channel I do Game of
Thrones every week be sure to subscribe
to get it
please leave all your video requests in
the comments below the more suggestions
that you guys give me for videos the
better our discussions are so I know we
got a lot of Spanish fans out there who
felt like he got a bad shake on the TV
show there's some big dramatic changes
from his book plot so I'll do a quick
recap of where he's at in the book
because as much as it sucks that he's
dead right now he's still alive in there
ramping up for their version of battle
of the bastards or at least the First
Battle of Winterfell the TV show
accelerated his plotline immensely up to
the end of season 5 so what's happened
is that Stannis listening to Melisandre
takes his forces to the wall he sort of
had most of those scenes that he has
with Jon Snow up there where they argue
over what to do with the wildlings then
eventually he decides to take his army
south to deal with the Bolton's because
they're still occupying Winterfell so
with the aid of the golden company that
we saw towards the end of season 4
Stannis gets the aid of the iron bank to
hire the golden company because the Iron
Throne has seized their payment they're
defaulting on their debt to the iron
bank so the iron bank is turning around
and supporting someone else's claim for
the Iron Throne so what he does is he
marches south from the golden company
with his forces trying to collect more
men he gets about an additional 3,000
men preparing for a battle with a Bolton
so we get help from the mountain clans
he gets help from the Glovers the
Mormont's the free folk house hornwood
house Carwin house tall heart they all
join Stannis just as if you remember on
the TV show Sansa and reek jump off the
battlements well in the books there's
Jane pool Santa's friends that they're
masquerading as Arya Stark as a front
for the houses of the north so that
they'll support the Bolton's claim on
Winterfell so Stannis is trying to
gather the support of the north the same
way that Jon Snow and Sansa did during
season six so the entire Jon Snow plot
between episode 3 and episode 9 of
season 6 is basically stand of stuff
leading up into winds of winter so if
you're really upset does that guy cut
blame Jon Snow
it's really not his fault he doesn't
know anything this is all in the name of
the TV show so they're preparing for
this giant battle against the Bolton's
we know what happened on the TV show is
that the Bolton's on a small raiding
party Ramsay cut down Stannis's forces
some of them deserted some of them died
so he was marching into what was certain
death that was mostly to put him between
a rock in a burning place when it came
to Shireen and Melisandre sacrificed to
the red God it is unforgivable as it is
if you're wondering why it had to be
Shireen why couldn't be Solis one is
royal blood flowing from Stannis and
Solis did not but - this is really cool
quote from Davos it says the Lord of
Light cherishes the innocent there is no
sacrifice more precious so it's talking
about the leeches incident that they did
with kendry so just another change from
the books but that's why Melisandre gets
really excited when she's asking Jon
Snow if he's a virgin so it's like you
have royal blood in you are you a virgin
you have the best blood of all so that
was intended to grant them the boon that
would allow them to win the battle but
that was all predicated on the idea that
Melisandre believed Stannis was the
person in her visions the one who was
promised which she misread Martin had a
really interesting way of addressing
that in the book through maester aemon
character who just feels like Melisandre
is completely misreading her visions
she's completely off base but on the TV
shows they didn't have that many
interactions between the two of them
come to the end of season five you know
how it all went down for Stannis he had
this small force going up against vastly
superior numbers of the Bolton's so
there was no way he was going to walk
out of that eventually after hobbling
away from the battlefield he took down a
couple more soldiers they gave him a bit
of a badass ending like he took them
down pretty quickly but then up walks
Brienne who had been waiting for salsa
so here's where we get to this moment
that completely changes Stannis's TV
character and you can let me know if you
agree with the way they did it on the TV
show versus the way they originally
intended it which was a little more book
accurate in the original version of this
scene they've wrote a bunch of extra
dialogues that humanizes Stannis's
character so Brienne walks up and says
do you have any last words
Stannis considers he says do you believe
in the life to come in Brienne nods yes
he replies I don't but if I
wrong and you're right tell Renly I'm
sorry when you get there
I don't imagine I'll see him wherever
I'm going he takes a beat and that says
my daughter tell her tell her any sort
of trails off the script notes read
sorry doesn't begin to cover what he
feels about Shireen the thought of it
brings tears to his eyes and he's not
going to die weeping in front of a woman
he doesn't know he doesn't know Brienne
so Stannis stares up at her and says go
on do your duty in Brienne nods
raises her sword and brings it down with
a mighty swing think about that extra
dialogue and how they highlight what's
going on inside his head how he feels
about it and then watch the scene as it
ended up on TV Vasily cut down I just
shorten this a little bit those women
try to enjoy I didn't fight for the
Bolton's I'm Brienne of Tarth
I was Kingsguard to Renly Baratheon
I was there when he was murdered by a
shadow with your face he murdered him
with blood magic
I did
in the name of Renly of house Baratheon
first of his name rightful king of the
Andals and the first men lord of the
Seven Kingdoms and protector of the
realm I Brienne of Tarth sentence you to
die
[Music]
do you have any last words
what do you do
[Music]
how much does it blow your mind that
Stannis is regretful and does not
believe in an afterlife he supposedly
worships the red God so he should
believe in a higher power maybe
something will be waiting for him after
but it sounds like he's given that all
up like for all his stoicism his
stubbornness and his belief in the
importance of doing your duty he's
having this existential crisis his
Brienne walks up and ends him in revenge
for Renly so let me know how you feel
about them cutting all that dialogue off
of the page it humanizes him a lot more
there were all those scenes leading up
between season 4 season 5 where he's
talking to Shireen about how she's his
daughter
you belong with me he seemed like a very
caring father for a very brief period
but you know come to the end of season 5
and it seems like they threw that
completely under the rug but again you
can blame a lot of these Stannis edits
in the name of Jon Snow Kit Harington on
the TV show because they basically gave
all of his plot from the last couple of
books to Jon Snow so that they can just
rush that plot along he gets to be the
person to unite the north not stand it
so you don't have another person going
into season seven who still has a claim
to the throat in his won this big
victory if you're really upset about the
TV show changes don't worry when the
winter will allow this to all play out
so you get to see what happens to
Stannis as martin intended it but you
can see how Dan and Dave working off a
lot of notes from George our Martin
we're trying to take things in the same
direction with some big edits where
necessary for characters they hadn't
already done or just times if they
didn't have to spend with characters on
big storylines like all the stuff that
was happening up at the wall in the
stuff that was happening down near
Winterfell let me know in the comments
too if you like me doing videos about
big changes from the books and how they
change characters in massive ways like
you think characters a certain way but
you find out about a couple lines of
dialogue that make them seem like
completely different people than what
you're seeing on screen so sometimes it
can be really interesting and then you
have characters like Arianne Martell Jon
connington that are just completely cut
out so once we get closer to wins the
winner being released we can do some
more book videos but a lot of it just
depends on what you guys are most
interested in talking about so that will
be happening later this year remember
Game of Thrones is going to be happening
all summer the book might not be
released till this winter
or even early next year but I will be
sure to add book updates when we get
them they'll probably be some more Game
of Thrones footage that'll drop in the
next month or two and I got a chance to
see the Game of Thrones a live concert
with for me and Djibouti I'm
mispronouncing his name but he's an
amazing composer
[Music]
[Applause]
it was a huge live show so if you ever
have a chance to see it they're still on
tour definitely try to go but a lot of
you been asking for a Varys video so am
i two of Aerys Targaryen restoration
Season seven video in the next week if
there's any other game of Thrones stuff
that you guys want me to do just let me
know in the comments while you wait for
that to post you can click here for that
season 7 teaser trailer and you can
click here to learn about all the stuffs
80s for season 7 at the South by
Southwest panel thank you so much for
watching clips high-five I'll see you
guys in the next video
you